hello everyone and welcome to a truly
remarkable game from 2005 from the
norwegian championship between magnus
carlson and atlegron yeah and i've
already shown this game it was some five
years ago back in 2017 and i'm now doing
a remaster of it if you guys uh watched
yesterday's video i mentioned that uh a
game that i'm very fond of is getting a
remake today was uh released uh or a
remaster uh so the the chrono cross has
been released and while i didn't expect
all that much i did expect a higher
frame rate so that's something that's i
mean 15 frames per second that's just no
way to live life in 2022
so i don't know i don't know how i feel
about this but uh okay i mean they do
what they they want to do but still 15
frames per second not all that great so
while i'm not gonna be replaying uh uh
replaying it anytime soon i'm probably
gonna wait if maybe someone you know
cooks up a homemade uh 60 fps version i
did decide to show you this game but now
in 60 frames per second because uh my
videos back then when this game was
first shown on the channel we're at only
30 frames per second so now i'm showing
it at 60 frames per second if you guys
want to check out the original version
uh feel free to do so it will be the
first link in the description below uh
but now let's check it out as it's one
of the greatest checkmates you've uh
well basically ever seen so
you might have seen this game but like i
said if you've uh if you've seen it on
this channel it was like five years ago
so let's dive straight into it uh 2005 a
norwegian championship magnus has the
white pieces this is round nine and he
opens with knight to f3 he goes for the
ready opening uh and here d5
we have d4
knight to f6 c4 and c6 so so far we are
playing the slav defense knight to c3
and e6 now they are transposing into the
semi slav
with bishop to g5 the anti-meran gambit
and now h6 challenging the bishop here
bishop to h4 and this is a perfectly
normal position that you might encounter
in
in in 2022 uh but uh here probably d
captures on c4 will be played this is
known to be the the absolute best move
also bishop to e7 is popular g5 is
popular but the move that atla played
here and that is queen to b6 uh is not
uh not the best one and it's only been
played a handful of times uh after this
game uh and okay magnus plays queen to
c2 he defends his b2 pawn
and now comes knight to e4 okay you're
challenging the knight here point is
that if magnus were to grab the knight
on e4 then it's not going to be
all that great especially if you capture
the pawn then you lose the pawn on b2
and now what do you play here rook to b1
okay you attack the queen queen c3
chicken already and black is
without any serious problems knight e2
you can play bishop to b4 and black is
doing great here so magnus continues
developing with e3 now the bishop is
ready to come into the game and here
bishop to b4 and it is already now as of
move 8 that this position has never been
reached again
and as you'll see for good reasons white
is white is pretty much already winning
but you have to play it very precisely
and magnus does he plays bishop to d3 he
doesn't care about um
the c3 squared there's really nothing
black can do about this but now he is
threatening to pick up this knight and
win uh win upon and improve his position
greatly so here queen to a5 and now
putting even more pressure on the c3
knight and magnus just castles here uh
so uh after castles we have knight
captures on c3 and magnus just plays b
captures in c3 he offers the c3 pawn
bishop captures on c3 and now rook 8 to
b1 so what's the idea behind this
position it seems that black just won a
pawn and if black can castle the safety
then black should be
not not just defined but even even much
much better the problem is if you castle
the safety here there's a problem with
bishop to h7 check king the h8 and now
bishop to e7 attacking the rook so the
only square for the rook is the e8
square and once you move the rook we're
gonna play bishop to d6 and now uh
now uh
what y did is it gained full control
over the b4 square and there's no way
for black to save the bishop on c3 so
pretty much whatever you play rook to b3
will be played in the next move and
you're going to lose the bishop there's
nothing black can do about this
uh so that's why uh
and of course
if you try something like g6 to trap
this bishop then we very gladly just
give it up and i mean now you're just
gonna get checkmated there's no stopping
this so it seems like black black one
upon uh very safely but how do you how
do you stop this uh idea of just um well
uh how do you castle or if you can't
castle how do you continue playing well
d captures on c4 first uh now attacking
the bishop so you don't have the queen
and bishop battery along this diagonal
uh bishop captures on c4 and now comes
the bishop back to b4 so now uh here
black realizes that the besh1 c3 might
not be placed all that impressively and
now the bishop will go back so here
knight the e5 by magnus uh and now okay
you could castle uh for example castle
then magnus play something like f4 then
the rook gets into the game but black's
main issue is that uh his queen side is
completely undeveloped and the queen uh
what is the queen doing on a5 and uh on
the queen side for that matter uh one of
the reasons why uh after this game
pretty much no one ever developed the
queen
uh
the b6 in that position uh so here
bishop back to d6 now you don't have to
worry about that bishop you can also
retreat with the queen f for now uh just
improving the position of course a
future rook lift is uh definitely
happening and now queen to c7 so you can
see how black wasted uh some moves uh
playing queen b6 queen a5 bishop to b4
just to bring the bishop back to d6 and
to bring the queen back to c7 so that's
not
a a great way to take advantage of your
moves so here queen to e4 by magnus
aligning the queen with the king
preparing to open up the position with
f5 uh and here black plays b6 now that's
uh this seems like a very odd move to
play uh but if you play something let's
say just castles which is uh well it's
what we all want to do then the problem
is knight captures on f7 and here black
just falls apart rogue captures f5 and
there's just no defending this uh it
will crack in in so many ways uh so
after queen to e4 b6 was played uh but
now or rather okay
you don't have to castle maybe you could
play f5 but this is still very very hard
to play the queen has to go back now but
even after castles you're gonna play e4
in the deposition will open up uh so not
not a lot of fun uh so for example king
h7 you want to get the king out of this
diagonal e captur c captures and now
something like queen h5 going after the
g6 square uh not much for black to do
you're to have to eliminate this knight
as it controls the g6 square if captures
magnus will get the the past e pawn uh
the bishops control e6 and e7 uh queen
controls e8 so this will be a very
one-sided game so okay getting back to
the actual position after queen e4 b6
was played uh and then now magnus plays
knight captures on f7 right away uh we
have queen captures on f7 and now f5 so
similar as in the position that we
discussed only here the differences
there's a queen on f7 instead of the
rook and you can't capture here to
threaten to pick up white's queen
because of course bishop captures an f7
comes with check so queen to h5 getting
the queen out of the way and now bishop
captures an e6 threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries uh
one well that plain one being just
capturing the bishop while delivering
checks so how can uh you stop this if
you capture the bishop that's not gonna
work just queen captures an e6 king f8
and now this f6 this uh just completely
destroys black in so many lines uh for
example uh you could try something like
bishop captures an h2 to stir some
trouble but after king captures queen
captures king g1 there's just no more no
more moves uh queen e7 followed by queen
to g7 checkmate will happen uh or if you
play uh captures then of course we
capture with the rook and you either get
checkmated or you have to give up the
queen and of course white will win this
very easily
so after bishop captures an e6 uh knight
to d7 is played because how else do you
uh stop this there's just no good way to
do this so knight to d7 now at least if
bishop captures you can capture with the
king here
but here comes f6 and f6 is a really
really strong move here because now you
freed up the f5 square and you can move
the bishop backwards to pick up the
queen while delivering check so here
knight captures an f6 there really isn't
anything better here now you are
attacking the white queen but now we
just eliminate the attacker of our own
queen and we will still be threatening
bishop the g4 with a discovery so rook
captures an f6 this is uh well it's uh
it is just beautiful and now again if g
captures bishop to g4 wins the queen
that's game over so queen to h4 was
played uh offering a queen to regain
some material maybe uh the problem is uh
magnus now has a forced check made in
six moves so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this magnus
checkmate while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not grabbing the
queen of course uh we can all grab the
queen but that's not the point here and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show the first mate in six is queen
captures and see uh c6 with check uh yes
uh you have to start with this and now
the thing is it doesn't matter what
black does so here k7 was played going
after the rook here now rook to f7 check
giving up the bishop and
you can't do anything here if you move
the if you move the king to d8 okay then
you survive a few more moves but still
king the d7 check king g8 bishop f7
check king of f8 queen captures and d6
check and now of course once the queen
blocks a queen capture 7 will be
checkmate it's a very very weird looking
checkmate uh not sure we've seen this um
that often
uh but okay after rook to f7 check um uh
gran accepts the bishop on e6 and now
magnus delivers his famous magnus
checkmate that's a queen to c for check
and now look at this the queen is
actually defending the rook by x-raying
it through the king and the king has no
square so this is a beautiful checkmate
here uh we can even uh you know uh draw
some red squares here there is nothing
for nowhere where the black king can go
and it's just a spectacular spectacular
finish so it all started uh a way way
back on move eight we were after e3 this
bishop to b4 move was played but even
before that when this queen decided to
go to b6 uh
the queen just has no place on b6 and
after this game pretty much no one uh
ever put it there anymore because well
bad things will happen and here even in
2005 magnus played this uh position
pretty much due to absolute perfection
uh so yeah i hope you guys uh enjoyed
this uh brilliant brilliant game uh in
60 frames per second no less uh i would
like to wish a very happy birthday to my
brother vikram aragopathy
and i would like to thank openc smokey
doula openc smokey doula open c smokey
doula and done other book for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh the coverage of
anything that's happening in the chess
world and of course checking up on your
wonderful uh suggestions uh so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
guys are interested you can check out
the 2017 video first link in the
description below see you soon